before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
well everybody likes a good race
[Music]
take two doctor who reviews continues
re-watching series 11 and we reach the
ghost monument now first an
acknowledgement of my first viewing of
this i remember very much at the time
liking this
significantly better than the woman fell
to earth not because it like was an
amazing blew me away episode but it had
a vibe and a sense and an energy that
was much more what i wanted or at least
what was appealing to me about this new
era of doctor who the woman who fell to
earth even on my initial viewing didn't
really
excite me this got me a little bit more
excited for how things would feel and
look going forward the scaled scope some
of the fine details that are in this i
quite enjoyed and re-watching it now
that's
still largely true there are a few
things that i look back on now as
someone who knows some of the stuff that
happens later and goes okay yeah
so that's not great and that's going to
become a recurring issue but also
interestingly
whereas i said in the last one there
were some instances of things that i
knew were going to be recurring problems
for me and i'm like oh boy here's the
first time right off the bat
here that kind of happens
but like in some cases in a way that
like okay this is gonna become a thing
that like is a recurring issue later but
kind of works here
it was strange there's like one key main
example of that being the case and i'll
bring that up when i get to it but can
we just start off i really do love this
title sequence
i love the weird ethereal blobby alien
nature of it and like i think most of
the best doctor who openings have a
sense of otherness of strangeness of
alienness who i mean like that's part of
what was appealing about the very first
time anybody ever saw doctor who that
sound that music those credits they're
weird
and i feel like this is the first time
in the modern era
that the credits have been properly
weird again
and i like it and i like the bass heavy
version of the theme i like these titles
so
this is the first time they appear they
get a shout out and then
pretty much right after
the titles we then hit
my first
uh main annoyance which is that the cast
just get randomly picked up by sheer
luck and coincidence which
i think like
i never got over it on initial viewing i
think i
let it not bog me down too much because
it's like the first thing that happens
and
okay like we had to get them out of that
situation somehow but i think it it
it should have been a little bit of a
red flag that after literally just
dropping them into the middle of empty
space at the end of the previous episode
the way that the characters get out of
it is out of
just an insanely improbable thing
happening by sheer luck and to sort of
paraphrase douglas adams space is big
space is massively and comprehensively
huge and the odds of being randomly
picked up by a passing ship when you're
out in the vacuum of space
is
astronomical now granted that also
happens in hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy but it happens because there is a
ship in use at the time that
the entire way that ship works is to
make the most improbable things that can
ever possibly happen
happen
so
like it's literally a plot point that
there's no freaking way this should have
happened but then it does because that's
what this friggin thing runs on
this has no such excuse they just
randomly get picked up oh okay
everything's fine now
it's
it's weird and i get the
i get the narrative need to have
sort of each half of the team get picked
up by a different ship in terms of
introducing each of these um racers and
whatnot but like the idea that one of
them spotted
two in the other spot of the other two
but didn't see the others like that just
doesn't
compute and then we also then have
coincidence on top of coincidence
because the ship that the doctor and
yazer on just so happens to crash right
where the other ones are now granted
like
they were kind of headed to the same
place but i didn't get the impression
they had enough control over that ship
to really control where they were
crashing and to and to be that spot on
again like it's nowhere near the
coincidence of the fact that they got
picked up in space but it's
just another instance back to back don't
love that there was something that i
thought of uh at the front end that
actually does get covered remembering
the characterization of the dude who's
involved in the race i remember thinking
okay but is he the kind of person who
actually would have stopped and picked
them up
because i don't think he is but that
does get addressed because both he and
the other racer thought that they were
bonuses which we just get through
implication were a part of the race up
to this point but the guy who running
who's running the race i'll come back to
him because i like him a lot he's like
no there's no bonuses at this point in
the race i had nothing to do with that
but it it is just a single quick
um just speed exposition bit that feels
like an actual part of a conversation
that explains why this dude stopped and
picked them up if he saw them so
they covered that at least so talking
about this guy who's effectively the
villain the guy who's running the race i
love this guy
what i love about him and his
performance especially is
just the casual
callousness of him they were hanging in
the star field when we exited hype are
you saying we scoop them for nothing yes
he knows what he's here for he is
running this race
he just doesn't care about all this
stuff that the
participants and now these four
strangers as far as he's concerned are
complaining about is like that's not my
problem and that goes right through to
the end i
love
love the way that it ends when at the
very end these two racers they come in
together they demand they get joint
first place he resists and then he's
like fine like that's a little weird
because it seems like he gives in
because they threaten him but like can't
he just leave them abandoned on the
planet but whatever he agrees to it and
then they're like get us off this rock
fine
and then
no
no
like that i love i love that no he's
just like
no and they're gone i love that i love
that casual
just
badness
the dude's just cows he's just a cow's
guy he doesn't care and he's not evil in
a muahaha sense he's just a completely
uncaring human being and that makes him
a problem and it's a problem they don't
get to solve or defeat because
that's not what they're here to do
they're just trying to get back to their
tardis so i love this guy
i love his vibe and i love the
performance i also gotta love that ryan
asks if they're eligible to participate
which again he's immediately like no
like not even up for debate um so
the other racers are decently done
they're pretty well portrayed the
characterization in the exposition is a
mixed bag there are some parts that work
some parts that are clunky so for
example i can't remember their names i'm
always bad at names i'm sorry but the uh
the woman racer she
you know talks up starts to talk about
how bad her home planet is and then like
when she realizes she started to open up
to yaz which is kind of a thing that yaz
tends to do is to get people to start to
talk to her which makes sense given what
we saw with her in the very first
episode and that right now
her policing is dealing with like small
local disputes and that's largely where
you just talk people down and get them
to talk to you so it makes sense and
then the instant she realizes she
started opening up she's just like i
don't know you
like that honestly a well-handled bit of
exposition the amount of information she
gave and the circumstances under which
she gave them and the way she delivered
those lines i bought as somebody sort of
losing their guardedness a little bit
and then suddenly realizing and snapping
out of it
then we've got the guy and things like
the story about his mother
and her lesson on
how you can't trust anybody and that
feels a little bit more awkwardly
inserted in there like i buy it as a bit
of uh explanation of the guy except that
like
i don't think that aspect of his
personality really needed much
explanation like
we've like as viewers we've seen reality
shows we've seen the competitor who just
does not care about the other people
involved and is only out for himself and
doesn't trust anybody like we know that
as a person as an archetype he is that
we don't need this thing inserted in
it's not the
worst uh sort of insertion of a
character exposition but it's also kind
of unnecessary and it is a little
awkward so coming back to what i said
earlier about having our first instance
of something that is kind of gonna be an
issue later and be done worse then but
actually kind of works here
is
what uh i've seen some hoodoobers uh
refer to as the
hey
how are you feeling scene because
the characters emotions are often not uh
particularly well explored in the moment
and so they have to kind of pause the
show for the characters to like check in
on each other so that the audience knows
how they're feeling this is kind of our
first instance with that with graham and
ryan while they're taking a look at the
engine on the boat but while i think it
is going to be a clunky thing later on
or at least to my memory here i think it
feels pretty decent
like they have a moment alone that is a
it it's a moment that felt organic and
made sense for them to be in the same
space together and be as alone as
they're gonna be under the circumstances
and to just take a minute
because this has been legitimately just
a roller coaster for them they were in
space they were on ships they were on
this planet they've been tr tracing
through the desert
like this is kind of the first even
close to a breather moment they've had
so it actually kind of makes sense for
me
that graham is like hey
how you doing are you okay
and invoking grace in particular also
made it feel
correct because like they're both still
in mourning
so
it makes sense to me that he would at
the first reasonable opportunity check
in with ryan this feels like it is that
uh
certain bits of it are a little clunky
towards the end because there's some
very on the nose dialogue of ryan going
you talk about this stuff too much and
then graham responding you don't talk
about it enough and while that
particular ending of the conversation is
a little bit on the nose it's
delivered well enough by the performers
that like it's okay
and i think honestly in this instance
it's a pretty decent moment there's
other little things that within the
confines of this episode work as
characterizing moments again we'll sort
of keep an eye out to see whether these
are built on or brought up again but
ryan is sort of the first one to really
legitimately question can we actually
trust the doctor given the situation
she's now put us in can she actually get
us off this planet like somebody should
be questioning that and under
circumstances makes sense to me that
it's him and then later on there's this
little moment for me as when i was like
hey we're on an alien planet la and yaz
just has this
smile when she responds to that which
that that is a good little
characterizing moment and feels like it
says a bit about her like she kind of
wanted an escape to run away from her
situation you get a little hint of that
here and we'll find out more about her
later that it absolutely fits i do like
in general that the doctor is the only
one questioning you know these ruins and
the circumstances of this planet being
like this is weird and wrong and
something bad happened here like it
makes sense that nobody else is
questioning it
but also she's the kind of person who
would be like no no let's let's not
gloss over this um as far as the threats
that are on the planet that's that's a
little bit of a mixed bag so
and a lot of this has to do with
execution
so there's the sniper bots so first of
all if you're gonna call something
sniper i'm gonna assume it's supposed to
be a crack shot and they're not very
good shots now first thing i'll say is
as far as instances of
something that should be just gunning
down the um the heroes easily but is
missing this is one of the better
executions of that just because of the
way it's shot the way the camera moves
the angles that are that are chosen uh
the fact that there's some emphasis on
the characters serpentining that makes
it work a heck of a lot better than
the stuff with like dan running away
from the centaurus which was
what
so
um while that is another thing that will
be a little bit of a request and then
like it's not just here that's been an
issue with doctor who for a while but
this kind of shows where
good filmmaking
you know good shot choice good uh
cinematography makes it work better so
there's that there's the and like here's
the thing them not hitting their shots i
feel like has a very reasonable
explanation that could have just been
dropped in as a line
all you have to do is say these things
are really old and probably haven't been
activated in ages
and then you know they're not as good as
shots as they should be i'd buy that
because otherwise these are created by
scientists who like are trying to build
ultimate weapons for a war-like race and
they're this bad at their shots like
just drop in one line it's an easy thing
to cover but they didn't i want to take
a moment to talk about ryan's dyspraxia
because it
it's getting a little
inconsistent here so because it does get
re-emphasis
on the two occasions in this when he has
to contend with ladders and that is
actually a repeat of a specific thing
got brought up in the last episode like
he does not like trying to deal with
ladders those are difficult for him
so that's good but
the moment that feels off is when he
grabs a gun and then runs out to take
down the sniper bots and his hit and
he's one-shotting them like one-shot
dead aim now
to be fair
i don't know a ton about dyspraxia it is
distinctly possible that dyspraxia in
general or maybe certain types of
dyspraxia and the way they affect
coordination
would not impact his ability to take aim
and fire with this weapon um but would
impact things like ladders that's
distinctly possible
but even if that is the case
i feel like when you describe something
that i don't think a ton of people know
much about
and it gets described in the previous
episode as a coordination disorder
showing a character doing something that
coordinated without
in some way addressing why this doesn't
throw him off but the ladders do
that it makes the moment weird and again
maybe it doesn't need to be given the
specifics of his dyspraxia but it feels
off for anyone who does not know
specifics about that condition which
i don't and i don't think most viewers
do
so
and it may just flat out be a mistake
it may be that his dyspraxia
should have thrown that off but even if
it isn't it feels like a mistake
because it's not
laying out
what is or isn't affected and it feels
like it they're just bringing it up at
certain times and ignoring it in others
even if that isn't the case it's what it
feels like coming back to some of the
threats so weird thing while there's
some specifics about it that i'll get to
in a little bit the general idea of the
cloths that are like fly and wrap around
heads and only come out at night
i actually kind of like it and the
reason i kind of like it is that it i
feel like it reflects
a non-human creativity
it feels like an idea that would have
come about from a society that isn't
earth-based with a completely different
history a completely different culture
and a completely different way of
thinking about how to lay traps and
attack people and make weapons
and
i like just the inherent implication
that this is the product of people from
a culture culture that just thinks
differently
so to us like that why would you make a
weapon like that to somebody it made
sense and that to me just kind of has
implications about the strangeness of
other cultures and aliens out there this
is just how they think
and it's different for it's different
from us
i like that intended or not uh i like
that that being said they uh these
cloths are also uh the mechanism used to
give us our first indication of
the timeless child
we're a ways off from dealing with that
properly but
uh
okay i'm not gonna get into my feelings
about the timeless child which aren't
positive but what i will say here
knowing what we know now
why do these things know
like they try and cover it by saying
like they read her mind
sort of thing like she has a whole line
get out of my head whatever and they're
also like oh she doesn't know implying
that there's something hidden in her
brain except that the implications we
get later is that there aren't hidden
memories they're just gone they were
wiped it's why she had to be put into
the matrix and shown them because she
couldn't just unlock her own memories
they weren't there anymore so what the
heck were these things seeing
that now that's a retroactive continuity
issue but
it makes an already sort of clunky
injection of what is going to become a
long-term mystery box
that
it was already kind of clunky and weird
and injected strangely and on top of
that looking at it now it doesn't really
make sense
circling back to the sniper bots and
specifically how the doctor and the
others get out of it um the doctor so
far as i could tell and like i even had
captions on to see if i was missing
something
just randomly finds an emp on the ground
now
we're already dealing with a lot of
preposterous coincidences
in this
and like i guess i could like headcanon
it's some sort of
emergency shut off if something went
wrong with the sniper bots i don't know
they don't cover it with any kind of
line on that but my bigger issue is that
she does that
and then says a whole thing about brains
over bullets brains
how is
randomly finding on the floor the thing
that just so happens to be exactly what
you need to get out of the situation how
is that being clever
now again there's ways to deal with this
if she had made the emp device out of
scraps that were sitting around that
while also a little bit contrived would
have felt more like a reflection of her
approach and her desire to out-think the
situation but like you just happen to
find this how is that brains and how
does that emphasize your point that
you're you're out thinking bullets cause
it doesn't make the point you seem to
think that it's making and also to come
back to it
her whole moment of guns never use them
like i'm not there's no problem with the
doctor taking that position i'd say the
doctor kind of should take that position
generally hasn't always the doctor has
picked up guns a few times even going
back to the classic era but
the way that it's delivered like she
just kind of says it like it's an
absolute and i get that it's an absolute
for her no
guns never use them but again it feels
like that sort of moral superiority that
i brought up last time and last time
that was in regards to carl kicking
simsa
off the crane but
this time while it is more consistent
with the doctor's like usual standard
sort of sense of morals there's just
she just seems to be evoking the sense
of i never use guns and i'm the moral
authority here
and it just comes off
weird to me and it's not necessarily
wrong you can have the doctor be
on a moral high horse and have that be
part of the personality but
it doesn't really feel so much like a
deliberate character choice so much as
the show seems to just be assuming
her moral rightness by default and given
that this is a whole new doctor with
possibly a new set of morals i don't
think the show
should just be banking on that concept
that she's right by default and can get
away with not giving some explanation or
justification now and as i said the
justification that she gives
retroactively we out think it doesn't
track with what actually just happened
the other thing about the weapons and
the dangers on here is they get tied to
the stenza
which in hindsight is very strange
because the stenza get built up here on
the back of the previous episode
and that
really never goes anywhere like zimza
comes back later on we know that but
it's one dude
what is the point of building up the
general concept of the stenza as a
species or as a culture when we only
ever see this one guy he's never in
command of more of them we never go to
their plan we never really
deal with this civilization we just are
dealing with the one guy so it's weird
that this episode bigs up like the whole
of the stenza when we're never really
going to address more than just the one
dude now i know i know it feels like
i've been complaining a lot and i kind
of have this is another instance of some
things are problems now that i know what
does or doesn't pay off or come back up
later but i know i still said overall i
do actually like this better than the
previous episode and that just largely
has to do with the energy and the vibe
of it this just feels
better to me as an episode as a tone as
an energy
and as a just he let's here's the
situation
let's go
and
that's the vibe i kind of wanted and
it's not quite there in the woman who
fell to earth so this was for me a very
reassuring episode at the time
and
as much as i've complained about the
specifics
i do still like the episode overall as a
vibe
a vibe's a hard thing to defend but it's
one of those cases where okay like
there's a lot of problems bits here and
there but it still
feels right and they're all there are
also little bits here and there that
work for instance at one point the
doctor gets asked i forget by who but
gets asked are you sure about this and
that archery just goes no come on and
like that
that's the spirit and the attitude i'd
like in most doctors so i was happy to
see that here
and later on when they get in the tardis
still don't love this tardis interior
i've talked about that elsewhere i don't
love the design but it is what we've got
but when they're inside because she had
thought she'd failed them before the
tardis actually properly showed up and
they get inside and i think it was jazz
pointed out what did you believe
yourself for a second back there who me
no
never doubted and at the time it felt
more like a joke but in hindsight
knowing that it's going to be a
recurring issue of how little she
actually opens up
to them how little of herself she
actually shares with them
that actually is a decent bit of a
foretelling moment
she was vulnerable for a little bit
there
and then denies that it happened
given that that's going to be a
recurring thing whether you feel that's
an issue or not it that one does feel
like a characterization choice
they're planting it early and with a
decent bit of dialogue that works in and
of itself so that's decently done and
that's kind of where i'm at overall
i like this episode i think the
performances
work pretty much across the board the
energy is good it again looks gorgeous
it's wonderfully shot and it just has
the feel and the tone and the rollicking
adventure energy that i was excited for
for this new series and i got it here
despite uh some of these specifics not
quite lining up or being slightly off or
being indications of stuff that's going
to go wrong later
i do still like this episode and i could
see myself re-watching this one just for
fun which i'm not sure i would do for
the woman who fell to earth
so
even now
as much as i rambled on about issues
with it i still consider this a step up
and it still feels like a good indicator
of what
this era
could be
whether or not it's what it actually
turned out to be
well we'll see how the re-watch keeps
going
but for right now the ghost monument
what you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it patreon's
how i'm able to pay the bills keep this
whole operation up and running like
share subscribe also help me out but uh
don't feel too much pressure about that
i mean there's other ways to give me a
little boost other things i do twitch
i've got books you can buy merch etc etc
check that out as well but
don't worry too much about it
what i really want you to remember
is that you're beautiful
you're valid
and you're loved
you're the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
it's the end credits means i gotta shout
out some patrons this month it is turok
oliver b linda walters tt robin powell
fronabilax the poodle idoln tracy
scrabbon dharma michael doyle vincent
paul bartolucci angry casper adam lefty
taylor robin moore shayla gourlay and
bookworm
thanks so much for your support
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]